Handsome Jack is buying
a pony made of diamonds.
The price of the
pony is P dollars.
And Jack also has to pay
a 25% diamond pony tax.
Match the expressions to their
meaning for Handsome Jack.
And they say
multiple expressions
may fit the same description.
So in this bucket, we have
the price of the diamond
pony before tax.
Well, they already tell us that
the price of the diamond pony
is P dollars.
So that's P right over here.
Now over here, they say the
amount of tax Handsome Jack
pays.
Well, he pays a 25%
diamond pony tax.
So whatever the price is,
he's going to pay 25% of that.
Or another way of
thinking about it,
he's going to pay 25% is
the same thing as 0.25.
So 0.25 times P is
the amount of tax
he's going to pay on
this diamond pony.
Now, they say Handsome
Jack's total bill
for the diamond pony.
Well, he's going to pay P for
the pony plus 0.25P in taxes.
So that is this one
right over here.
P for the pony plus
0.25P for the taxes.
So that's that one over there.
But if we look at this, you
could view this literally as 1P
plus 0.25P's.
Well, that's the
same thing as 1.25P.
So that's the same thing
as this right over here.
So it's 1.25P.
And these other three
don't seem to fit
in any of these categories.
So I'm going to put
it into the not used.
We're required to
categorize everything.
So let me put this
in the not used.
It's falling off the
screen, I realize.
Let me put this in the not used.
And then let me put
this in the not used.
Let's check our answer.
We got it right.